The only purpose of dyes is it's cosmetics.
So they are basically makeup for our food and medications.
Hello, everybody.
This is Dr. Camden Cutters.
Welcome to another episode of Cutters Clinic Live.
Today I have some special guests who just are putting out a wonderful
documentary dies in the effect of dyes in your health, causing cancer,
causing hyperactivity, causing brain issues, brain inflammation, all sorts of
things. I'm going to let them do most of the talking.
It's branded and Whitney Kaywood.
And I'm going to have you just jump right in, introduce yourself, tell us
how you, why would you do a documentary on this, tell your story?
All right.
So I'm Whitney Kaywood and this is Brandon.
He's my husband.
So I have a background in education and after I decided to quit teaching,
I went into marketing and we started to have children.
And after we had our first son between the ages of, or our only son, we have a
daughter between the ages of one and three, he was like a bit of a puzzle.
His behavior was kind of erratic in that some days, most days were really
rough with the tantrums and the fits and the hyper and the, um, just like
inability to cope just with everyday emotion, which I mean, if you've had
a young child, you know that that can be normal, but the amount of times we were
having fits and aggression and hitting a day, um, it was a lot.
So we're having trouble at daycare.
We're having trouble at church.
We were all the things and we decided to do an elimination diet.
We eliminated a wheat dairy and synthetic dyes.
And once we eliminated those, we saw like just a traumatic, a dramatic
difference in our child.
Um, and so it was pretty shocking.
Um, we reintroduced wheat and we saw no effect.
We reintroduced dairy and we saw no effect.
And when we reintroduced dyes, it was within 15 minutes, the fits and the
hitting and the aggression, it just came flooding back.
And so that kind of sparked our curiosity, um, about synthetic dyes.
And I asked, I was really curious about what was going on in the brain.
And if it could affect other areas of our life, if it could be, you know,
causing cancer or causing colitis or any, any other issue.
So I decided to kind of dig into the research and I was really confused.
Even reading the abstract was confusing to me.
So I really wanted to interview the experts and ask the questions that I had.
So I asked Brandon if he wanted to document our journey as I just tried to figure
out, um, and get to the bottom of synthetic dyes and he agreed.
So, so yeah, so we, uh, we embarked on that journey.
I have a background in my day to day.
I am a commercial photographer and, and videographer.
I do, you know, advertising work and things like that for businesses.
And so we had never taken on doing like a long form video project.
So that was new.
But as far as like creating videos and things like that, that was, I mean,
that's what what I do every single day.
So she had to convince me a little bit because, you know, we knew it was going
to be a, I knew it was going to be a lot of work.
I had no idea how much work it was going to be after two and a half
years. We're finally done.
But, but, uh, so yeah, we embarked on that journey and it started off slow.
We didn't know who we were going to get to be in the film.
And luckily door after door was open, you know, God opened a lot of doors for us.
He introduced us to the right people.
And so we ended up, you know, the center for science and the public interest is
a big part of our film.
And we went to Europe and interviewed Dr. Jim Stevenson, who is responsible for
the, the study that is why the European Union has a warning label on, on, uh,
dies.
And so we really got, you know, the best people in the world to kind of back up
this information.
And then our documentary is also about 50% story based.
So we interviewed affected families across the country and we hear their stories.
And then we have the science and the film that kind of backs up what they're
saying, what they're talking about, kind of, you know, a lot of times you have
an issue like this that's not super well known, people kind of, kind of
think you might be a little kooky or a little crunchy or, but, uh, you know, we've
got, we've got the researchers and the studies and the science in the film to back
it all up.
Well, and you would probably be interested in the beginning of our journey.
The reason why I wanted to embark on an elimination diet is because I have a
lot of autoimmune issues.
And I realized once I completely changed my diet, almost all of my issues went
away.
So I knew the power that binding foods that were harmful to me and my body and
that everybody's body is different and unique.
I knew that that, you know, it could make a difference and it's not a cure all for
everyone, but it really significantly helped me relieve, you know, my symptoms.
So we were really shocked that it was dies because we were really expecting it to, you
know, the dairy and the wheat to have more an effect because he was eating it so much.
And I think one of the most shocking parts about our journey is that synthetic dies or
not something that he was getting regularly.
We weren't doing the sugary cereals or the, the pop tarts or the sweet treats every day.
Like he really was just getting it daily through an allergy medication.
He had chronic ear infections.
So he was on antibiotics and he was on a daily allergy medicine and been in drill to clear
up any kind of fluid that was in his ears.
And so like we were really shocked that just taking that away and then the occasional birthday
parties, we would swap out treats at birthday parties.
But we were really shocked that it made that big of a difference.
And fast forward now he's in first grade.
So we have a wonderful public school.
He's in a STEM school and he's doing German immersion and from pre-K all the way through
first grade, we haven't had any issues.
We haven't had a single meltdown.
We haven't had the hitting or the fits.
He's just thriving.
And so for him, it was a 180 flip.
Like it completely took care of any issues that we were having.
And before that, we had actually been asked to leave his mother's morning out.
So like things were, which is like a half day day care.
So things were really rough at church at home and at school.
And then now things are just so much better, which that's not everyone's story once again.
He is unique in that.
He reacts more strongly to synthetic dies than most children.
But there are those children in this journey.
We started a group right around the time we decided to start a documentary.
We started a group that's grown from zero to 580,000 almost 590 almost 590,000.
And so we've heard hundreds if not thousands of stories that have been so similar to ours,
which has been really affirming in that we need we need more information out there.
So that's our story.
That's where we're at.
Well, I want to touch on one point you said, you know, you weren't eating a lot of foods
that had a lot of dyes in it that you could identify.
But it was daily medications, they're putting this in medication.
So he was taking a menadryl with maybe a red diet or something.
That was to clear up the inflammation in his ears, but it was actually causing inflammation.
I have a whole course on chronic disease on autoimmune.
One of my main points of that is to find your triggers and they're different for everybody.
And they can be there can be multiple triggers.
So anything that's going to stimulate inflammation of the brain is going to be a trigger.
So dyes are horrific for that and especially with kids and I just want to make a statement
that you know kids before age two to three have no blood brain barrier.
So if you're putting something in their body, it's crossing the blood brain barrier that
has not existed.
So the blood brain barrier made up by the astrocytes of the brain doesn't form until after that
time.
So toxins from vaccinations, from medications, from foods, whether it be dyes that we're
talking about today or some other inflammatory toxin is going to go into the brain and affect
the brain.
And it can be praise God that your son had a 180 degree turtle, but there's a lot of kids
that this could affect them for life.
It could be large.
It could cause demilinated diseases and all sorts of different problems.
But one of the one of the driving factors for us making this film is the fact that we recognized
it.
We hadn't have figured this out like how long would this like how long would he have gone
it was painful with with this behavior should he was having trouble making friends he was
having trouble, you know, getting along with with his teachers and things like that.
So we're like, there's got to be other kids out there whose parents have no idea that
dyes are a contributing factor to what's going on with them.
And if you spend a whole life consuming dyes and it's affecting you in this way and you
don't know it, like that's crazy.
Well, and how would that lead you to feel about yourself as well because he was the kid.
He was the kid that was an issue and he kind of knew that.
And even at three.
Even how did that feel about you as parents too, as a mom, I've never been in a darker place
never.
And so my mental health was struggling.
I felt like a failure and I really like to be a prepared person like I read the books.
We were eating mostly organic foods, which was ironic.
We just did not think about medication.
And so I really tried my very best to do all the things and to listen to all the podcasts.
And you know, we were just grasping for straws to figure out like something that could
just help him just a little bit, just a little bit, just a little bit.
And so once we eliminated the dyes, it really was pretty dramatic in that.
The fits and stuff stopped right away.
But then we still had those occasional like slip ups where we wouldn't think about, we
would go camping or something and we wouldn't think about dyes being in marshmallows.
There was a spinach wrap that I had and I thought that it was green because of the spinach
and it had yellow five and blue one.
And so we had a really rough week that week because I was giving him, you know, I was making
like, I call them egg tacos or egg quesadillas a couple of times a week and dyes, it's important
to note that it stays in your system for a while.
And I think everybody processes it at a different time.
But for him, for 48 hours after consuming even like one mini marshmallow, he would just
have just a really, really rough time.
And we tested that one time actually.
He, I was making like hot chocolate, like homemade hot chocolate for the teachers for Christmas
time.
I was putting marshmallows on the top and he saw marshmallow that fell on the floor and like
an animal ran and grabbed it and put it in his mouth and I was like, oh no, and I turned
it over.
And I was like, in a white marshmallow.
So it's really permeated a lot of foods you wouldn't expect.
We've seen it in canned foods, we've seen it in spices.
I mean, we have an entire list of just really, really surprising places that you have find
it.
And it's not always the sugary colorful cereals or the sugary colorful treats.
I mean, it's even permeated like cosmetics and mouthwash.
Cool.
Yeah.
White icing, vanilla icing, chocolate icing.
And so you can't really look at a product and see, does this have dyes or not?
Well, the only safe bet is if it's organic, then it is innately die-free because organic
foods cannot be synthetically made and synthetic dyes, even though it might say organic, not
everything is organic in the product always.
That's a valid point.
Oh, it's, I mean, praise God, you guys searched for this.
I mean, what are the, what's the vast majority of Americans do?
They run to the doctor and there's a doctor going to go, you should look at dyes, you should
look at your diet.
No, they're saying we're going to give your kid a label so that it excuses you for being
a bad parent.
And then, I'm glad you said that, that was our story, that was our story.
We would go the doctor and try to get help.
We would, we did behavior therapy, the, you know, the doctor, the doctor, all the doctor,
all the petitions never even brought up diet or food like what we were eating.
It was always, you know, they wanted to get him evaluated and things like that.
And so we tried to, we have pushed back on the evaluation because he was three years
old.
Well, and the doctors agree with us at the time.
If this continues until he's six, like they said, you can go and go hang in evaluation
and get started or you can wait until he's six because some of these behaviors are quote
unquote normal until you're six.
And so that, that really was the suggestion that we had.
But in the, once we figured it out and, you know, on this journey, we've actually, you
know, we've, we brought this information to most of his pediatricians.
They had no idea.
And so it's been, it's been interesting to, you know, as a, just a regular person, you
assume that your doctors know, know everything, you know, you assume that they, you know,
everything that there is to know about health.
And so it's, it's kind of been interesting to see that it's not something that's super,
super.
I've been doing this for a long time and here from cancer patients all the time, well, that
oh, diet has nothing to do with it, you know, let's just, it's insane, it's insanity.
Because it defies common sense, right?
Right.
I mean, any thinking person would go, is there a reason for this?
Let's figure that out.
So hats off to you guys for digging into that.
I know you love your child and it, but there's a lot of people that really love their children
who don't do this.
You know, so to get this information out is crucial.
Thank you.
We also realized too in our journey, like a lot of the medications for, you know, like the,
you know, things like ADHD and things like that.
And a lot of times children or people with, with those, you know, the medications to treat
that a lot of times also have dies and people with ADHD and even our son, our son is on
the gifted spectrum.
You've noticed that, you know, even any, like we noticed a lot of, like the neuro divergent,
like spectrum of people, like they tend to have a stronger reaction.
And so a lot of those medications for those things have died in them as well.
We had somebody also epilepsy.
We had a person in our group write us about their child that had epilepsy, and you know,
you can't not take your epilepsy medication.
But she had actually had a physical allergic reaction to red 40.
So she couldn't take.
There was two options.
One with red 40 and the other one is red 3.
And so she's having to take red medication with red 3 and every single day because to get
it compounded would cost her, you know, a thousand bucks a month and she made note that they
can't afford a thousand dollar medication without her getting a second job, which is, I mean,
you think about that.
It's going to cost her time with her children even more time, even though she's a full-time
job.
And the scary thing about red 3 is, it's a pretty alarming die.
So back in 1990, the FDA themselves from a study from the 80s where they fed red 3 to rats
and the rats got tumors.
So the FDA themselves stated that it caused cancer and they banned it in cosmetics and externally
applied drugs.
And they had already permanently approved it in 1969 for food and ingested drugs.
And so for 34 years, the FDA has been saying that it takes steps to remove red 3 and it's
still out in food and ingested drugs.
And you have to just wonder, why in the world are they putting dies in a drug that you're
swallowing?
Is it getting people to buy the product more?
That's your exactly right.
The only purpose of dies is it's cosmetics.
So they are basically makeup for our food and medications.
And so we as Americans, often times like very beautiful, vibrant, cohesive medications
and foods.
So it's used as a marketing piece.
It doesn't help foods stay stable longer.
It has no purpose other than to make it look beautiful.
And oftentimes dies are used because a manufacturer has decided instead of using strawberries, a real
food, they've decided to use a natural flavor or an artificial flavor, which is colorless.
So if you have a protein powder where you have used an artificial flavor and it's colorless
but you want it to be a strawberry, you want it to look like strawberries.
So to make it look like real strawberries, you add the color to make it look beautiful
so that it looks like a strawberry.
When they really could have used strawberries to begin with, but the reality is synthetic
dies are cheap, they are oftentimes a byproduct of petroleum, which compared a byproduct
of petroleum, the price to a real strawberry.
Like that's very different, but it's obviously the cost of consumers.
So I think with medication, one thing that they use it also is like an identifier for certain
medications, but there's so many ways that you could press pills, different shapes and
things like that.
You know, there's ways that you could do it without coloring it.
So yeah, that's pretty crazy.
Yeah.
Well, your journey has led you to really learn a lot about this subject, not just for your
son, but you have a greater purpose to share with other people.
You touched on, you have a Facebook group, is that what it is?
We do.
Let's talk a little bit about your social media content that you have out there and how
you're trying to reach people to that, because obviously, what are the better ways to do
that?
Right?
Yeah.
So around the same time, we decided to do the documentary.
We wanted to start a group, too, so we could go ahead and really start helping people who
wanted to eliminate dies.
So we have really worked really hard to create resources and lists and just really make it
easy for families who want to cut out something like synthetic dies.
And so for a lot of families, they've never even read an ingredient label, they've never
looked at it, they've just bought food and eaten food.
And so just thinking about a label and reading a label and finding dies on a label can be
challenging.
So we've really created several resources, like one of them that is really popular is we have
a synthetic dies list sheet.
And so we have, we've listed all the dies.
And if anybody's wondering, the non-approved synthetic dies used for food, cosmetics are
a little bit different, but it's red 40, yellow 5, yellow 6, blue 1, blue 2, green 3, red
3, yellow 2, and orange B.
And so we create the list of citrus red 2.
And then we also say like why we should avoid them, so there's a number of reasons why you
should avoid them.
We also have a list of unexpected foods that you can find dies in and then like synthetic
die-free brands.
I also, each holiday, I create lists that help families just enjoy like Christmas, for
example, die-free or Halloween die-free.
There's a lot of swaps that use artificial, I mean that use natural dies compared to the
synthetic dies.
And so we really have tried to make it easy for families.
We as humans are aware that dies are not the only issue in our food system.
But what we've noticed is that by cutting out synthetic dies and by learning about synthetic
dies, it's almost like a gateway drug into like realizing like there are things in our food
that we really should be avoiding.
And so for me, as we went along this journey, one of the most shocking things, which it won't
be shocking to you, but one of the most shocking things to me to discover is that synthetic
dies are a chemical.
And when I heard that word chemical, I was like, oh, I didn't know there are chemicals in
our food.
And so once you get that information out there, people are really starting to just really
be critical thinkers about what they're putting in their bodies.
And so our group is die-free family, recipes, resources, recipes, resources, and swaps.
And swaps, recipes and resources, there we go.
We'll have lakes for that, and we'll leave for more lists because I don't where lists
that are going to want to get that list.
Yeah.
So that's our group.
We have Facebook page for the film.
So we've got about 40,000 people, we just broke 40,000 people on our films Facebook group.
And on that one, we do some of the similar stuff we share resources, but that's really close
to about the film.
What's going on with the film?
Things that are happening in the news.
Things that are happening in the news, things that we're learning about every day.
Whitney was saying, that was her most surprising thing that she learned.
My most surprising thing that I learned on this journey, even though it doesn't necessarily
involve synthetic dyes, was learning about the grass list, the generally recognized
the safe list, which is nice.
And so as you said, like, learning about dyes is a gateway to other chemicals.
Once you find out that there's thousands of chemicals that the FDA has never even looked
at that are allowed to be in food because of this loophole, it's crazy.
Yeah.
Yeah, we need to be aware of natural and artificial flavorings, they're all artificial, they're
all fake.
So the thing is that our government is allowing this insane, I interviewed somebody from Europe
a little about a year ago about chemicals and cosmetics.
There's over 900 things that are banded in Europe that are approved in cosmetics in the United
States because they're banded in Europe because they're carcinogens.
And yet they're allowed to, I guess the bad side of capitalism, you know, it's driven
by money so strongly that there's people, I mean, in power that do not care about your
son or your grandsons or grandchildren or you, they don't care whether you live or die,
whether you get cancer or not.
That's the sad reality until we face that fact, we, we don't take responsibility.
And I think that's, to me, that's what I always preach is that you've got to take responsibility
for your health.
Nobody else is going to your doctor's not a government's not you have to take responsibility
and that needs educating yourself.
So I'll get your documentary is to die for the documentary, we're going to have a whole
bunch of information on that, tell us when it's coming up.
So we don't have a concrete day yet, we have, we have like a penciled in date, but it's,
it is going to come out January 2025.
So the day that it comes out will, will announce as soon as we have that locked in, but it will
be out January 2025.
And right now we're currently in the process of like an impact campaign.
So we're, we have a press release that just went out last week and it's, it's floating
around the trades, like the, the film trades first.
That's what our, we have a distributor now and we'll announce that who that is and stuff
soon too.
But so about a week we'll be able to send out our press release to, you know, different
organizations and media outlets and stuff like that.
So with our impact campaign, we're wanting to kind of partner with organizations, influencers,
things like that to do private screenings and use the film to kind of, you know, as a education
piece and get the word out there, spread the word out there, try to get it in front of
as many politicians as we can, senators, state representatives, things like that.
And hopefully we can, we can go ahead and build some momentum before it releases in,
in January.
So I want to speak to what you said about Europe and because something I found that was really
interesting is Dr. Jim Stevenson, we interviewed him.
He's a researcher responsible for the warning label in the EU and I, I was asking him about
the study.
I was like, how did you get funding for this study?
Because all the researchers we interviewed, they want to do further research on synthetic
guys in the US, which we have enough, there's 27 clinical trials on children in regards
to hyperactivity aggression and things like that.
So we really have enough, but they would be curious and would like to do more research and
they cannot find funding.
They've applied and applied and applied.
And so I asked him, I was like, how did you receive the funding?
And he was like, oh, it's government funded.
I was like, oh, the government was concerned about their citizens and I think the reason why
that is is because they have some ownership in healthcare in Europe.
And so they carry some of the burdens of healthcare and here in the US, we were paying for therapy,
we were paying for doctor's visits, it was coming out of our pocket.
So I thought that that was interesting.
I really think you should have some organizations that step up and really re-evaluate the chemicals
that are in our food so that we know that they're safe and so that we as citizens don't
have to look for these foods and see if they're safe or not.
We just...
Well, also in Europe, the approval process is more of a...
We need to prove that it's safe before it's allowed, whereas here in America, it's more
like, well, we're going to allow it until we prove that it's not safe.
And in the case of red, three we've known since 1990 was the year before I was born 34 years
ago, that we know that it causes cancer.
And so...
And it's still in...
I mean, up until a few months ago, it was impede assure.
It's in medications.
It's in things that...
The worst part is whenever it's in medications that children take daily.
And so I think your audience would be interested to know that there's a few other things.
Although our film focuses on diets and behavior, but it also focuses on the cancer and how
some of these diets can be carcinogenic.
And so we know that red 40 can increase or susceptibility to colitis.
Yellow 5 and yellow 6 may contain carcinogenic components like we know that.
We've had a lot of allergic reactions with yellow 5, yellow 6 and red 40, so it's causing
a lot of hives, throat swelling, things like that.
We know that red 3 and yellow 5 can be genotoxic, which can cause DNA damage that can be passed
from your child to their children or from you to your child or can cause tumors.
And so these are really dangerous chemicals.
They look pretty and they look harmless, but they really are not good for us in any way.
Well, and I want to touch on some practical things too, like some people don't want to.
What am I supposed to do?
I have a single mom and I said my kids to school and they eat the school lunch because
we get it at a disc culture for free.
What are some practical things that you would answer for somebody's situation?
That is an issue and that's something we touch on the film.
The free and reduced lunch program, there are a lot of products in the free and reduced
lunch program that contain dyes.
So we're pushing in our film for people to contact their state senators and state representatives.
You've just seen a week and a half ago, maybe two weeks ago, California became the first state
to bands and all the synthetic dyes in public schools.
So by 2027 in California, synthetic dyes won't be allowed in the free and reduced lunch program.
So we're hoping that's a problem.
They're hoping that's a problem.
They can be out of California.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, in California, California also is the only state so far that has band red 3, so they're
They're a good starting point with dies and they're such a big part of the population
that they can cause some ripple effect and the fact that like our manufacturer is going
to continue to make a, you know, the rest of the country with the die in it and make
a separate version for California, I don't know.
So luckily California has done that but we're hoping that that will be a ripple effect.
We hope that Georgia can be the second state to do, you know, that would be the second state
to bend synthetic dies, but I think the grass roots effort is so key.
I mean, you didn't see any of the organic space, you know, 10 years ago and just the supply
of demand.
So people have thought to stop buying this stuff.
Right.
And so practically what you, you mentioned a single mom and we actually interview a single
mom in this film and it is a struggle, but you're, it's going to take a lot of time and
effort for you, but you can figure it out.
So our son, we normally pack his lunch, but on occasion, we'll let him eat at school.
And what we do is we call, I have a really good relationship with the lunch room.
And so I call the manager and I say we're eating lunch today, can you double check everything?
And luckily for our school, that we haven't found very many synthetic dies and we are free
and reduced lunch school, but I have seen letters from people in our group where the lunch staff
will get back and be like, yeah, it's in our pizza sauce, it's in our fruit cups, it's
in like really places that are surprising.
And so it's really hard for children, especially if you are dependent on a school lunch, which
oftentimes can be 70 to 80% of the food that a child consumes daily.
They can't avoid it because there's not a label on their, on their school lunch.
And so they kind of have to eat what is given to them.
So that is an issue obviously.
On the flip side of that to know to avoid it at all, you got to know that it's a thing
and it's generally not something that most people know, right?
And so for school parties have been an issue for us because parents always want to celebrate
birthdays at school.
So what we do logistically is we just, we make little mini cupcakes and I let my son pick
out what kind he wants and we just make it a really fun treat and we keep them in the
freezer.
So we treat it almost like a peanut allergy.
We keep it in the freezer and then whenever those surprise parties come, they just pull
it out.
So we send swap boxes and we just tried to think ahead of each holiday special occasion.
And we bring something that is a safer swap for us.
So those are some of the logistics that you can do.
It is difficult with with the mom that we interviewed.
What is difficult, the most difficult for her is the medication issue.
And so her son does also have ADHD and he does take medicine.
And so when he went up from 1 milligram to 2 milligrams, the 2 milligrams had dies whereas
the 1 milligram didn't.
So it took her two weeks, a back and forth and back and forth and back and forth and advocating
to try to get insurance to cover 2, 1 milligram pills so that he could take 2 milligrams instead
of 1 milligram.
And so she also has to work with a compounding pharmacy.
So it is difficult and I do think that it obviously should not be a medication that something
we are really passionate about.
And that is something that not a lot of advocacy groups are talking about but it is something
that we are really hoping that our film brings to lie and so that people can know that it is
an issue.
Well, not to brush past school lunches too much like I do think it is kind of an unfortunate
thing.
Like she said, a lot of times people don't know that they need to be avoiding it.
And if you are on the free interduce, if you qualify for free interduce lunch, that is
a big part of your nutrition and it is like you need to eat the food.
And so what we are hoping that we can inspire people to do when they are contacting their
state representatives and think about that, it is a really question, is it ethical to feed
children something that is known to cause behavioral issues and hyperactivity?
DNA damage.
Is it ethical to feed them these foods and then punish these kids for behavior issues in
school?
Like school is the one place you should be trying to avoid anything that could affect
behavior negatively like at all costs.
So hopefully and I think that is what is happening in California, like the California is also
where the Weihar report came from which is the leading report on synthetic dyes that we
have to date.
It was like a big meta study, meta analysis where they brought in all the studies.
Most comprehensive and rigorous undertaking today on the relationship between synthetic dyes
and its effect on children's behavior, 27 clinical trials, underwent peer review, public
comment, and so it is the most comprehensive report in the world.
And so, I mean, it is concluded, it concludes a lot, I mean, it concludes all these things
that us as parents have been saying for a while that it causes, the conclusion was it causes
it in some children, it can cause hyperactivity in the teniveness, restlessness, sleeplessness,
irritability and aggression.
And they also found that women and children that are in higher poverty, that are in poverty,
that they are consuming the most synthetic dyes.
And they have the least access to, you know, die-free foods and it also found that eliminating
synthetic dyes is far more effective to treating ADHD than any other non-drug treatment for ADHD.
So, I mean, it's very, I think that it's pretty sound, solidly backed by science, which
very often doesn't happen whenever you're in like the crunchy world.
It takes a long time for science to catch up, I feel like, so.
Yeah, actually, you're just bringing to light the science that has already been done.
You're right.
I do want to touch on what to think, because I think there's a lot of people out there
that are going to make the mistake and think, well, I ate that when I was a kid, you know,
and I'm fine, but they have to look at the data, because the same food that you ate when
you were a kid, I don't know, let's say Cheerio, something like that.
So, you're giving it to your kids and giving it to your grandkids, did not contain the dyes
in the artificial colors, in the artificial flavors that it does today.
Even though it looks the same, it tastes the same, it's not the same product, and there's
a lot of data out there on so many processed foods that have changed because they're less
expensive to make, putting different, different, artificial flavors and artificial colors in
them.
So, I think that has to be.
You're right.
You also have to look at that dye, and the way it affects people is kind of like the
spectrum, right?
So, you have, like, you know, Dr. Stevenson's study pretty much showed that it does affect
the general populations, but it's a spectrum, right?
So, you have kids in the normal area of the spectrum, and they can assume that it dyes,
and the effect it has on them may not be able to notice a big change.
So, those kids don't seem like they're being affected, but then you have kids on the low
into the spectrum who, you know, who are right at the edge of behavior issues and needing
medication and things like that, where synthetic dyes can kind of push them into that, where you
have kids on the higher end of the spectrum where they're right at the edge of being exceptional
or gifted, and the synthetic dyes are kind of pulling them back, pulling them back away.
So, yeah, our entire population.
And to your point, the use of dyes have gone up dramatically since we were children.
And so, the two points I would make is that the use of dyes have gone up a lot, and then
also, are we okay?
But yeah.
Like, the amount of friends I have that struggle with, you know, they're tired, they're sleepless,
they are you aggravated, are you struggling with anxiety and depression, like, there's
a lot out there, and there's a lot of, I mean, millennials are struggling.
Yeah.
And there haven't been many studies on the effects of dyes in adults, you know, it's mostly
but most of the studies have been on the effects of dyes in children.
And I can say that it affects me, and I did not know that it affected me until I went on
antibiotic that was red, and I was up the whole 10 days I took it all night, just like, could
not sleep for days, and I could not figure it out, and then I finished up my round of antibiotics,
which I thankfully have not taken antibiotic in, like, two years now, which has been good
for me.
There are adults that have claimed that they are affected by dyes, and then obviously,
you know, the cancer and the genotoxic, and all of those things affect us as an adult as
well.
Well, and I would argue I have a video on our autoimmune course on neuroinflammation and
microglial primate, that these chemicals dyes at the colorings and additives and things
are a major cause of dementia, Parkinson's, all these neurological disorders from autoimmune
issues to, you know, early onset dementia, which is just, like, insanely growing the Alzheimer's
and people are saying, well, it's because people are living longer, no, actually our life expectancy
has dropped, and the incidence of Alzheimer's is just going through the roof, and it's because
of these neurotoxins.
So, and from a neurological perspective, you know, it is, when your excitatory neurotransmitters,
you know, particularly glutamates in the brain are near that excitatory threshold, anything
can tip them over.
You talked about a spectrum, Brandon, and it's that spectrum when you're closer to that
threshold of firing, neurons are either they fire or they don't fire, but when your neurons
are closer to that threshold of excitatory neurotransmitters firing, and you have that stimulation, it
doesn't take much like you noticed in your son to cause behavioral issues, well, maybe
in adults it's not so much the behavioral issues, but it's just things because you can temper
it down with your choices as an adult, but it's causing neurological damage that constant
chronic inflammation that's causing neurological diseases.
And if you look back at like when they when they started to remove lead, you know, like,
like it's the things like that, because, you know, lead was affecting the brain and was
affecting IQ and also that like they actually saw a drop in like crime rate and stuff.
So it's kind of a similar comparison, like, you know, these little shifts in the, you
know, the IQ and the population, they may seem small, but on a global scale shifting the
population in any direction is not, you know, especially in a negative direction is not
good.
Right.
Well, now let's get to how, how we could help you not just us in our clinic, but how anybody
listening to this can help you get this information out.
Well, there's a few ways.
We have been very fortunate that God's given us like a little army, like a little social
media army.
So you can join that army and you can help us spread awareness.
You can share resources so that people know that there are options and we would just want
to help as many people as possible.
You can join our email list and when you join our email list, we update you on what's
going on in the news, like right now, there's a petition that's going on.
So we are not us, but food babe, which is an influencer in the space and she, she's an
activist and an influencer and she is petitioning Kellogg's to take out artificial dies.
So we update our audience on how they can help and be a part of the change.
We also on our website, we just created a resources page where we have like social media
templates that you can post and you can share your story and just engage your audience.
We also have letters that you can write to your school board, like letter templates and letters
that you can write to your state representatives to ask them to band dies in your state and
the schools in your state or to band dies altogether or to add a warning label, whatever
your heart desires.
But yeah, we really just want you to think about one, sharing your story if you have a
dies story or just sharing that this can be an issue at Taekwondo yesterday, our son takes
Taekwondo and I was talking to a mom and they have a child that they're adopting that's
just really, really struggling and she had never heard of synthetic dies.
And so I was able to give her that, I'm not sure if that will be, you know, the golden ticket
for him, but it could help.
And so I just think people using their voice, using their stories to share that these
dies are harmful.
I think that those are all really wonderful things.
Well, and I think that the film, I think the success of the film is going to rely on like
a word of a mouth type, you know, like a grassroots word of mouth.
Yeah, and I don't think that we talked about this and that Brandon and I, we're two people
and we've created this documentary, like we are not, we've not been paid by anybody.
We have crowdfunded, but we've put a large amount of our savings into this because we're
so passionate about it.
And so like our audience knows that and they have been fired up to get this information
out.
And so although we don't necessarily need the monetary support, like we really do need people
to share and to spread the word because the more people that we have on our social media,
the more people that's talking about it, the more likely we can get this in the mainstream
media, which I'm sure that you know is incredibly difficult.
Well, yeah, what we're hoping for too is we're hoping that, you know, it's very hard
for us to connect to every organization that could find some use with our film and it's
a very hard for us to connect with every single influencer that might be able to use this
to help their audience or or politician like.
So hopefully that we can help, we can have people help us with that, you know, just let
people know that this film exists to anybody that that you think could find a use for this
film and use it as a resource to educate and to help to help change and help move this
movement forward.
We invite anybody to come to our pages and take our resources and send them out and get
the word out about the film.
Well, Brandon, it's been a pleasure to have you.
I'd like to have you back, actually, and hear more about this.
I think to talk about this is key because it's grassroots.
That's going to grow this, this is just like any other information.
So we'll get information attached to this podcast about everything that we talked about.
These lists are so important.
Your website is so important.
Once you give that verbally again, anyway, just listen.
Our website is to die for the documentary.com.
And it's a D-Y-E.
D-Y-E to die for D-Y-E.
And then if you want to go directly to, we actually have a list set up just for podcast
listener.
So if you go to die for the documentary.com backslash podcast, singular and up plural, then
that'll take you to our podcast page.
And you can fill out.
Then we can just kind of keep up with people that have found us through listening to podcast
or if you just go to die for the documentary.com, there's another sign up that puts you in
our general newsletter as well.
Well, thank you.
We're going to be prayed for you too, because I think you're up against a opposition that
isn't the favor of this.
And we got as bigger and put this on your heart to be your mission and I'm thankful for you
guys.
Thank you so much.
We'll have you back.
Thanks again.
We appreciate you.
Bye-bye.